I like working with Quentin Tarantino  and I watched an actor struggle because  the the set was like  it was Heavy I mean you had  you had Samuel Jackson here you had Leo  I mean it was some juggernauts you know  come on [ __ ] say that [ __ ] Christoph  wasp's process wasn't that I'm going to  have all of these things memorized and  do all of these things at once he would  give you these and calm yourself  gentlemen one more time  foreign and we were watching it and Leo  was like  I said Leo you think you got it he's got  it  just keep watching  and you see all these little bits of  things and then all of a sudden in the  movie boom calm yourself gentlemen I was  like oh [ __ ] and then I'd like to thank  the academy  [Laughter]